welcome to this video playing haga again
this guy was always playing 1b3 maybe he
had I don't know some sort of yeah
sentence and post them in a court case
you have to play b3 the rest of your
life something like that isn't this a
bit bit dull doing this all the time but
he's doing it b3 all the time ok I'm we
have a reverse Sicilian and with my
current shape i'm really looking for
some kind of a tech here even if it's
totally incorrect I don't mind him don't
want some some slower slow maneuvering
game and maybe I can play Bishop a
six-year this capture this capture I
don't know about should basics come on
isn't this isn't this night see force
what he wants to do with
i wonder if i should i come on I don't
care really the way I'm playing at the
moment I should just just do that and
see what happens getting two pawns I can
take c6 okay rook v8 you cannot castle
at the moment and the ideas supply route
could be 6 cm if I had Bishop f6 and
then a somewhat bad moment so this is
why I played rugby 8 first Queen see
three days you for this should be should
be quite nice okay so probably Queen
back here okay we are still this you
form with some some play yep come on
let's do that takes Queen takes 90 for
the c5 so this is not possible hmm isn't
this interesting already
that's interesting play unless I'm
completely overlooking things which is
very much possible but looks nice oh
isn't it
ninety-four there's also c5 and maybe
there are even other moves but c5 just
regaining the peace should be quite good
96 I can just take leading to a very
nice position
you
yeah I think I should just take it up or
do I have something better I don't think
so this is just very nice getting back
some material and the question is now
Queen g5 queen age for this kind of
moves they look very promising yeah
Bishop c3 is also not bad but Queen g5
is very tempting yeah let's do that the
question is here I thought maybe Bishop
deform this could be good Bishop d4 if
it takes III well that's quite strong I
can also give the check here for more
simple for more simple play but this
looks nice also threatening Queen f4
takes you three quite strong I think
check
yeah maybe you can just play king of
three and survive all that maybe check
this is dangerous but maybe not winning
cannot go up he ate yeah it's not
winning okay check me to give this check
then maybe opening Bishop b4 here I
don't have the rookin play that's really
problematic be this checking on g2 and
on b3 and the king of course take here
or take here um this is actually winning
back some material probably probably
this is the easiest or not the easiest
the best one I don't know yeah rook
takes Queen ER three check wins back
something rookie one Bishop e3 is even
better so probably check this was the
best way to play now yeah to check take
it probably and watch now I need to get
the rook into play Queen B 7 that's
rookie seven but then I have to check
with Luke Luke c8 is my idea but k can
probably just move the king of this
wasn't a good idea
yeah that was a bad move king queen bee
7 or to crack move just passive is this
is just passive I needed to play
something like h6 anyway okay how do I
get you want to want to get the seafoam
may be here with rook c8 and no Queen
trade not not easy behav here 55 now
time morning this is probably very risky
what I'm doing
check-check
that was lucky lucky lucky break him
check now at the end the time cost 94th
it's hard time ahead at a very nice
position here maybe queen bee three
years better I don't know it's just
about equal confessor totally unfazed
check here okay here Queen takes d4 is
minus 10 okay Jack Queen a1 checkmate
yes that's not very difficult once you
see it it's very easy Queen a one made
ah yeah not not a good shape not a good
shape check yeah well the whole thing
was awesome very very much a gamble but
they are he right here the computer is
giving it is about equal interestingly
enough and here I'm already okay really
okay yeah see five black wins and here
Queen age for Checker's immediately
winning Queen h4 g3 queen age five and
Queenie to mate Wow yeah as mentioned
you're not in any good any good good
shape him this is however with Queen D
for which I didn't you check and around
here he served God so this was just bad
luck windy son just a passive moose yeah
yeah it's probably equal I didn't want
to draw though and continued and I will
hear white is just much much better with
the deep
on chat I was just just lucky that that
you fell into this into this trap okay
thanks for watching